later today we expect to hear remarks
from president biden announcing major
new sanctions against russia in a
statement overnight the president called
the invasion a needless act of
aggression against ukraine and global
peace and security he also said russia
alone is responsible for the death and
destruction this attack will bring nancy
cordes is at the white house what i'm
sure is a busy white house this morning
nancy good morning good morning adriana
it sure is the president has been in
contact with his national security team
throughout the night he also spoke by
phone at one point with ukrainian
president zielenski he has called an
emergency meeting today of g7 leaders
all the shelling that holly described
actually began during an emergency u.n
meeting in new york last night which
demonstrated how isolated russia now is
present putin in the name of humanity
bring your troops back to russia
as diplomats from around the world
issued urgent pleas to russia's leader
the u.s and europe turned the financial
screws vowing to freeze the assets of
and ban travel by members of putin's
inner circle his defense minister his
chief of staff even a well-known tv
anchor known for spreading propaganda on
russia's state-controlled network
u.s officials are now threatening to
block russia from obtaining computer
chips and other technology critical to
its military and aerospace industries
we have more steps we can take and we're
going to continue to apply those if he
escalates russia's economy is already
feeling the effects
moscow's stock market losing about 20
percent of its value just in the past
week but the crisis is also rattling u.s
investors
u.s stock futures plunged overnight as
the u.s average for a gallon of gas
climbed to
3.53 cents a gallon
oil topped 100 a barrel for the first
time since 2014 and since russia is a
major exporter of oil and natural gas
this invasion is likely to put increased
pressure on the global supply chain
forcing prices to rise even more
two u.s officials tell cbs news that at
this point no one sees a chance for
diplomacy in this situation president
biden is expected to speak to the nation
later today where he'll lay out those
severe new sanctions he is ready to
impose
earlier this week he ordered the
repositioning of american troops that
are already based in europe to support
nato allies in the baltic states but he
has reiterated that he will not go to
war with russia itself tony
nancy thank you very much